katarina rupak is anxious for the past
eight years the 32 year old German has
called the UK her home she studied here
rents her home here is employed and paid
taxes here but when asked to
retrospectively account for her time in
the UK time she spent abroad unemployed
when she does not have a continuous
record her online application granted
her pre settled status while her
boyfriend who followed exactly the same
trajectory but with the UK employer was
given settled status if they are to
status and one of them is better than
the other and obviously I have been here
since 2012 that's obviously the one I
would want to go for and ultimately I
still feel that even the Home Office
can't really tell us what this status is
what it's worth so let's say I would
like to try and rent again find a new
flats let's say I try and apply for a
new job or maybe even want to buy a
house how is that the state's perceive a
new study shows those concerns are
shared by many launched by the campaign
group 3 million they say some who had
not yet completed the online application
were being discriminated against they
cited evidence of employers withholding
job offers people being denied health
care and others prevented from opening
bank accounts so in the survey we have a
quite a high number of people who are
choosing not to apply for different
reasons and the one high bracket there's
people who don't apply out of principle
a lot of them have been at home in the
UK for a very long time and that clearly
is playing a factor part in their
decision not to apply they feel revolted
disgusted by the fact that they even
should have to apply and therein lies
the crux they say if it was a
registration system we might well do it
but an application system very different
it's estimated that tens of thousands of
people have still not applied and when
the deadline expires in less than 18
months we'll be left without legal
rights at risk of eviction detention and
deportation the home office a 2.5
million people now have secured digital
status and from the majority the
application process is working well but
according to this report 90%
people say they want a physical document
to prove their right to stay in the UK
rather than just relying on digital
evidence without it they say they will
feel unsettled and on Monday the House
of Lords supported that request
contradicting the government's own
advice in a move that would be welcomed
by all EU citizens who call the UK home
Charlie Angela al-jazeera London